[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon I'm Paul gray and it's my
pleasure to welcome you to this the
seventh and final Ford MIT
Nobel laureate lecture on behalf of the
Institute I would like to express our
gratitude to the Ford Motor Corporation
for its sponsorship of this program over
the last five years Frank will check
received the Nobel Prize in Physics in
October 2004 and I quote from the
citation for the discovery of asymptotic
freedom and the theory of the strong
interaction and quote professor will
check who is the Herman Feshbach
professor of physics came to MIT five
years ago in 2000 following appointments
at UCSB the University of California
Santa Barbara at Princeton and at the
Institute for Advanced Study he received
his bachelor's degree from the
University of Chicago and his PhD from
Princeton University and I should note
that the work that is principally
recognized by the Nobel Committee in
this award was work that Professor
willjack did while a graduate student at
Princeton no one would ever accused the
Nobel the Swedish Academy of Sciences of
rushing to judgment professor will check
is one of the world's most eminent
theoretical physicists he has received
numerous honors fellowships and prizes
and he is beyond all that a very
distinguished science writer before I
ask him to come up let me remind you
that there will be a reception in the
lobby of the auditorium following the
end of this presentation the professor
will check will take questions at the
end of his presentation I had the
opportunity last Friday to hear
professor will check when he addressed
the Institute's governing board and I
know that you're in for a treat as he
speaks today on the universe is a
strange place please join me in
welcoming
professor we'll check
[Applause]
all right
the universe is stranger than I have
thought so my theme today is the
universe is a strange place and I'd like
to start by justifying that with
reference to the part of the universe we
do understand and so we can be sure it's
a strange place by describing the theory
of our part of the universe that is the
part that consists of us among other
things the material we're made out of
the material in our immediate
environment the stuff that chemists and
biologists deal with then we'll get on
to the really strange stuff later in the
lecture so the picture that modern
physics provides of ordinary matter is
strange in many ways in quantum
mechanics atoms appear as musical
instruments not in a metaphorical way
but in a very precise way when Bohr
introduced his model of the hydrogen
atom based on quantized planetary orbits
the primary formula of that model the
Bohr model of the atom was a formula for
the frequencies of light that's emitted
in terms of various physical constants
and pure whole numbers these 1 over N 1
squared minus 1 over N 2 Squared's so it
was an appearance of formulas for
frequencies very reminiscent of the
formulas you would get for determining
the frequencies of music that musical
instruments can emit but here it's the
frequencies of light and because of that
when Einstein learned of this model and
of some of its successes he called it
the highest form of musicality in the
sphere of thought ironically
quantum mechanics later became much more
musical and Einstein didn't accept it
let me show you
in a way that's more eloquent than
equations you can ignore this this thing
streaming by this is this is a wonderful
piece of software by dean dowager called
atom in a box that in real time computes
the wavefunction of the hydrogen atom of
electrons circling a nucleus and a
hydrogen atom and allows you to see how
the patterns the stable wave patterns of
electrons change as you emit different
kinds of light you can also look at more
elaborate wave patterns by superposing
it's a wonderful program and you really
ought to look into it and even pay for
it if you're it allows you to play
microcosmic god spin the atom around and
the point is for those of you who's seen
things like kolodny patterns or
sprinkled filings on a drum and watch it
be hit these are the kinds of things you
see these are wave patterns it's in fact
the equations of musical instruments are
exactly the equations one encounters in
describing what happens inside hydrogen
atoms according to the quantum theory
the modern quantum theory
so that's the physics of the 1920s as
things have developed through the 20th
century we've succeeded in understanding
much more about matter not only about
the structure of the outer outer parts
of atoms the electron wave patterns
around the central nucleus but also what
the nuclei themselves are made out of
and so we have a pretty complete picture
of ordinary matter and according to this
picture which has been rigorously tested
in many ways matter is made from
electrons and photons or really fields
named the electron field in the photon
field that create and destroy photons
and electrons the photon field is also
called the electromagnetic field and as
we saw it's really filled in the
description of electrons the electrons
are not to be thought of as particles
but as spread out objects as wave
patterns and then you learn in high
school or even maybe in grammar school
that the other fact about ordinary
matter the other constituent of ordinary
matter the atomic nuclei is made out of
protons and neutrons and that represents
the physics of the 1930s when physics
when Chadwick discovered the neutron in
the early 1930s in 1932 and people
thought that that was an MLM entery
particle and as was a proton and you can
build up the description of matter by
getting an accurate picture of how
protons and neutrons interacted but when
they looked into it in more detail they
found that protons and neutrons were
actually very complicated objects is
very hard to read the message they
described
then thanks to work by Jerry Friedman
among others and theoretical work by
Mary go man and others it became clear
that there were simpler objects inside
protons and neutrons inside what are
called nucleons included that were
quarks and there had to be something
else to hold the quarks together but
that was unclear what it was and it was
my fate sorry to figure out that besides
the quarks there is something very
precise that we can describe gluons that
make up the protons and neutrons and
nothing else
that that's a complete description and
furthermore it will become important
later to know that the theory of
electrons and photons is very very much
parallel to the theory of quarks and
gluons the theory of quarks and gluons
is a a more elaborate mathematically
complex version but a recognizable
version of electrodynamics called the
non abelian gauge Theory where the
quarks play similar roles to electrons
and the gluons are a generalization of
the photons how do we know something
like that how do we come up with a proof
that those are the constituents of
matter and that's what I'd like to
describe in the next few minutes this is
a tremendously beautiful picture also
due largely to MIT physicist I give us
different version of this talk elsewhere
this is a picture of an event taking
place at the CERN accelerator near
Geneva at the so called large electron
positron Collider this red stuff is all
equipment this is the beam pipe these
are different magnets and detectors what
you're the the physical part are these
tracks of particles emerging and what
you're seeing here
are a quark and antiquark and a gluon
what's done at this accelerator is over
and over again electrons and positrons
are collided with one another and what
comes out is this is studied it's a very
profound point although not often
remarked in this context that the that
the fact that you don't get the same
thing coming out every time even though
you put the same thing in is a direct
manifestation of the quantum behavior of
quantum mechanics that there's a
probability of different things
happening you don't get a determinant
result from the same input and one thing
that happens fairly frequently is that
you get bunches of particles coming out
like this so-called Jets most often you
when you get Jets you get two Jets an
equal and opposite to opposite
directions 180 degrees apart we
interpret that as a quark and an
antiquark when you get three Jets like
this we interpret it as a quark and
antiquark and a gluon what does that
mean interpret it I mean they're not
particles they're not single particles
there are these conglomerates of
particles what gives us the right to
make that interpretation much less think
of it as evidence for the idea that
matter it is made out of quarks and
gluons and that's really where
asymptotic freedom comes in asymptotic
freedom is the property of our theory of
quarks and gluons a very difficult
property to property to realize
consistently in quantum mechanics and
relativity that in our particular theory
of how quarks and gluons interact with
each other
radiation events that significantly
change the overall flow of energy and
momentum at high energy are very rare
whereas radiation events that don't
change the overall flow of energy
are quite common that immediately gives
you the interpretation that what we're
seeing here is a single rare radiation
event where the quark and antiquark
receding from the initial evolution
initial annihilation event emitted gluon
that significantly perturbs the overall
flow of energy and momentum but then all
the other radiation events are of the
common variety that produce particles
produce radiation of quarks and
antiquarks and gluons but don't change
the overall flow so the initial
direction and the amount of energy in
these different jets is set by the
underlying quarks and gluons and the
hard radiation events but then they get
dressed up by the common soft radiation
events so you don't see the single
particles literally but only as Jets
however if you do a soft focus and
instead of following the particles
individually just sum up all the energy
and momentum in these things in these
Jets then they should have the
predictable properties of individual
quarks and gluons and we have the
precise theory that describes that basic
interaction and that enables you to end
comparing with the experiment comparing
the probability of having two Jets
versus three Jets versus four Jets the
different angles at which they might
emerge with different relative energies
with different and how all that changes
as a function of the energy of the
initial Kani elation allows you to test
in great and rigorous detail the basic
assumptions of the theory and make sure
that it's correct so we can be pretty
sure that what we're viewing here is a
quark and antiquark and a gluon we can't
tell which is which because that's been
that's obscured by the dressing process
that goes from the individual particles
to the Jets but if anyone tells you that
you can't see quarks you can tell them
that it's a lie that you do see quarks
and anti
or ten gluons quite literally just not
as individual particles only as the
imprint of energy and momentum in jets
so that's a little strange
pretty but it enables us to be sure that
or that we have a fruitful theory that's
actually predicting results of
experiments and can be falsified could
have been falsified but in fact by
comparing results of measurements at
this kind of this experiment and others
like it what you find is that you can
fit them all done at different energies
here that this indicates the overall
energy different energies that the basic
principle of asymptotic freedom that
enables the whole machine to run that is
that radiation events that take a lot of
energy are rare and so correspond to a
small coupling small value of this
coupling so high-energy radiation events
are rare whereas the energy radiation
events that only involve small changes
in the flow small CH transfers of energy
and momentum we say are quite common so
that's a gift from heaven which enables
us both to see the basic interactions
and to understand that why they were
obscure before at lower energies why
things get complicated
so that I think is to the educated eye a
convincing demonstration that there are
quarks and gluons and that they interact
in the way that this elegant
mathematical theory predicts but it
doesn't really but it leaves a question
both of intellectual closure and of
credibility or the need for clarity that
is we're claiming that the things that
make protons and neutrons and you and me
and ordinary man
things that have mass are these strictly
massless gluons that are like photons
and quarks that are almost massless that
have masses much much smaller than the
protons and neutrons themselves and
we're claiming that's all there is or at
least that's the simplest form of the
theory how can we convince ourselves of
something like that how can we rise to
the challenge of computing not only what
happens at high energies but how these
soft radiation events these low energy
radiation events orchestrate themselves
into the particles including protons and
neutrons and you and me that we see how
is it possible to construct heavy
objects out of objects that don't weigh
anything and the answer to that
challenge comes from Einstein's second
law
Einstein's first law Einstein's famous
law is e equals mc-squared before
telling you what Einstein's second law
is I'd like to relate a story during the
Second World War the army had to train a
lot of radio engineers rapidly from it
from people who didn't necessarily know
much about radio engineering or even
basic electricity and it's a job that
they managed to do very very well and
successfully and we can look at the
textbooks they used at the time as
models of teaching and in the Army's
training manual for electrical engineers
in the first chapter you will find a
description of Ohm's 3 laws they're
Ohm's first law is V equals IR ohms
second law is I equals V divided by R
and I'll leave it to you as an exercise
to figure out ohms third law in a
similar spirit together with Einstein's
famous first law a equals MC squared
we have Einsteins second law M equals e
divided by C squared now that may seem
silly to just rearrange things
algebraically you can't and consider
that as a different law but it's not
completely silly it's a primitive
version of what the great physicist Paul
Dirac called playing with the equations
because writing essentially the same
equation in different ways can suggest
different things in this case it's very
true if you think about e equals
mc-squared famously
what it suggests is the possibility of
getting large amounts of energy from
small amounts of mass and so it suggests
things like the possibility of making
nuclear weapons or nuclear reactors that
get a lot of energy out of doing strange
things to mass but if you write it this
way it suggests something different it
suggests the possibility of explaining
mass purely in terms of energy in fact
really this should be called Einstein's
first law or as maybe his zeroth law
because this is the form that he
actually had in his original paper in
the original paper you will not find the
equation e equals MC squared but rather
this equation M equals e divided by C
squared and the title of the paper was a
question can the inertia of a body or
does the University of a body depend on
its energy content so right from the
beginning
Einstein was thinking of the possibility
of creating mass out of pure energy and
remarkably enough that's what actually
happens in our modern theory of quarks
and gluons and the strong interactions
I won't try to describe that in
technical detail but I'll show you some
pictures that suggest some of the
mechanisms that come into play which are
really very very beautiful very very
unexpected and very very different from
what you learn in elementary physics in
quantum field theory we discover that
what appears to us as empty space is in
reality a wildly dynamical medium as
well as the famous uncertainty in
position and momentum that is encoded in
Heisenberg's uncertainty relation in
relativity there's a related form of the
uncertainty relation that relates energy
and time that is if you study things for
short enough times you'll find that the
energy fluctuates and in particular that
means that you can borrow energy for a
very short amount of time to create
particles and antiparticles so-called
virtual particles and so if we look at
even at empty space with a very high
resolution in time we find that it's
full of all kinds of particles and
antiparticles and falls and forms a
dynamical medium because these particles
and antiparticles while they exist can
interact with each other in effect also
the properties of other particle real
particles that happen to be around these
virtual particles are so important that
I wrote a sonnet about them and with
very little prompting I'll recite it
okay virtual particles beware of
thinking nothing's there remove what you
can despite your care behind remains and
what a mindless sieving of mindless
clones beyond conceiving you'll get the
right version if you buy the book
actually
they come in a wink and dance about
whatever they touch is moved by doubt
what am I doing here
what should I weigh these thoughts can
induce rapid decay fear not the
terminologies misleading decay is
virtual particle breeding and seething
though mindless can serve noble ends
this clone stuff exchanged is a bond
between friends
to be or not the choice seems clear
enough but Hamlet vacillated and so does
this stuff so that's the poetic version
and here's okay and here's the even more
poetic version due to Derrick line
webber
this is actual calculation of virtual
particles that is fluctuations actually
taking the equations of this basic
theory quantum chromodynamics
discretizing them putting them on a
lattice and just solving for these
quantum mechanical fluctuations and this
is what you find this is not an artist's
impression this is data and well the
data is somewhat massaged of course they
don't really they don't really come in
colors they're not really this big
they're not really this smooth most
important but for experts what this is
is the smooth topological charge density
and this is going this QCD lava-lamp is
what's going on in empty space all the
time within you and me according to our
correct theory of the strong
interactions QCD and this dynamical
vacuum has many consequences one of the
consequences is asymptotic freedom which
I mentioned that this is the kind of
dynamics that underlies that phenomenon
but it very much relates to this problem
of calculating the masses of particles
and accounting for the mass of the
proton and neutron and ultimately
ordinary matter
because I told you that mass corresponds
directly to energy or Einstein told you
that actually but I agreed
[Laughter]
so the different particles we observe
therefore correspond well they
correspond to different vibration
patterns very different stable vibration
patterns in space
remember the description of particles
even for electrons was waves so they're
all vibration patterns moving in
different ways and stable particles that
we identify a state as particles and can
reproduce are just vibration patterns
that have a particularly long lifetime
that we can identify over and over again
and the they so in that language the
different particles we observe
correspond to vibration patterns that
occur in this dynamical void when it's
disturbed in various ways this language
is extravagant if you're just doing
ordinary quantum mechanics but if you're
doing quantum field theory and doing QCD
it really is the right language you have
to use it and here's an example this is
how one produces in again in these
numerical experiments and again this is
data a particle we notionally plunk down
a quark and an antiquark here it's you
can do that very conveniently
numerically even though it would be
right it quite quite a challenge to do
it cleanly in a laboratory so then they
run free they settled that they create
disturbances in those fluctuating fields
their presence they have influence and
they'd create disturbances in those
fluctuating fields if we average over
the fluctuations and just keep the net
disturbance created by having an extra
quark and an antiquark around this is
the extra disturb
in the fields this is much smaller than
the fluctuations by the way but you
average over the fluctuations because
that's empty space we measure energies
relative to that and this tells you what
the particle is the particle is this
particular excitation in empty space
otherwise empty space it's this pattern
that persists over time this is actually
the PI on there would be similar
pictures if you looked at protons and
neutrons so this is our deepest
understanding of what protons and
neutrons are there are these stable
vibration patterns in the dynamical void
now let's play with equations a little
bit because it leads to a very beautiful
realization so we had this a equals M
equals e divided by C squared if we
actually want to use those numerical
experiments to calculate the mass well
we don't get to weigh those things those
numerical patterns there's no we don't
it's complicated to build in a
gravitational field and see the response
what's much easier to do is to exploit
the Planck relation between energy and
frequency so you see the frequency of
vibrations of the fields and relate that
to the energy they're carrying according
to e equals Planck's constant times the
frequency and so when we actually want
to measure the masses what we actually
look at numerically is these frequencies
and use this equation now if we call
that the first law of determining masses
then the second law would be this one
which expresses that every mass is
associated uniquely with the
corresponding frequency
that suggests something different that
suggests something very beautiful and
poetic actually the masses of particles
are not are like not are similar to not
our metaphorically suggested by they are
the tones the frequencies of these
vibration patterns in the dynamical void
here's what comes out of the
calculations numerically and these
calculations by the way are very hard
work mostly hard work by computers but
also some hard work by the people who
program them and it's a very important
activity in which MIT and plays a
leading role with John Naegele and and
Rupert insky especially what comes out
of these kinds of calculations is
convincing evidence that this theory of
quarks and gluons really duh and nothing
else really does account for the vast
bulk of the mass of ordinary matter here
and in terms of very very few parameters
I haven't emphasized it and it would be
hard to do justice to it in the talk
like this but the theory is so
symmetrical so tight so on the verge of
being inconsistent that it's difficult
to change in any way it has very few
adjustable parameters if we fix the
adjustable parameters the mass of the up
and down quarks from the PI on mass the
mass of the strange quark from the K on
mass then nothing else remains to be
fixed and you get predictions unique
predictions for the masses of a lot of
other particles strongly interacting
particles that have been measured
including n here n is the nucleon those
are the proton and neutron and so we
really have accounted quantitatively
using this simple mathematically simple
but profound theory of quarks and gluons
for the mass of protons neutrons and
ultimately you and me and everything
around us in our immediate vicinity
so the ancient dream that there was a
music of the spheres emitted by planets
circling around the Sun or even earlier
I guess planets circling around the
earth that ancient dream which always
was nothing but a dream it didn't have
any rigorous content and so has
quotation marks has become something
quite rigorous quite literal and even
true that there's a music of the void
and to read it to hear it what you have
to do is look at the table of particle
masses that's it those are the tones
emitted by the void so from this little
survey of our strange understanding of
the part of the universe we do
understand in a profound way I think we
can draw two great lessons first of all
if we work to understand then we can
understand in the late nineteen as late
as the late 1960s and early 1970s
physicists despaired some physicists the
faint of heart
despaired of ever understanding this
mess of the strong interactions Freeman
Dyson who is probably the most brilliant
person I ever met and a very
distinguished physical physicist said
predicted famously in 1969 that it would
be a hundred years before we began to
understand the strong interaction but
four years later we had the theory and
it came about because there was
freewheeling research along many many
lines some of which seemed unpromising
some of which was hard to assess and
much of which did turn out to be
unfruitful but by a vast effort
involving many many physicists
experimentalists and theorists over an
international community sharing values
of openness and honesty so that
they could correct each other and learn
from each other we we humans did manage
to understand and find this world which
is so remote from our everyday
experience and then secondly that the
part of the world we understand is by
any standard strange and also I think
quite beautiful it's even more beautiful
if you study the equations and
understand it properly but I hope even
these pictures and rough indications
have indicated some of it so that's the
part we do understand now I'd like to
and that's ordinary matter things of
things around us where you really
understand quite profoundly in the
reductionist sense I think we're close
to closing on that we know we really do
understand the behavior for ordinary
matter and its basic properties in
principle under ordinary conditions with
a very very wide definition of what
ordinary means that would include
everything relevant to chemistry biology
astrophysics but in cosmology we meet
our match and in cosmology we don't know
what's going on astronomers recently
have found that ordinary matter the
stuff I've been talking about so
rhapsodic Li contributes only about 5%
of the total mass in the universe so
that makes stars galaxies nebulae
planets people frogs things like that
but it's only 5% of the universe as a
whole if you count by mass 25% is in
some mysterious dark matter it's well we
don't know what it is it's not really
dark dark it's transparent if it were
dark then by studying how it absorbs
light we could determine its properties
but in fact it's imperii impervious to
light it's been impervious so far to all
the normal mechanism e optical Astronomy
radio astronomy even new tree
no astronomy the Dark Matter has only
been detected through its gravitational
influence on ordinary matter which we
can't see from that we learn how much
there is and that it clumps and that it
exerts very little pressure and and then
of course we learn from what it doesn't
do that it interacts very very weakly
with ordinary matter there are some
ideas about what that might be some very
good and exciting ideas which I'll come
to momentarily 70% of the mayart matter
in the universe 70% of the mass I should
say when you average over the universe
as a whole on very large scales is in
something called dark energy which is
even more weird this is very evenly this
is evenly spaced as if it's not clumping
at all as if or in other word to an
intrinsic property of space and time
that space weighs a little bit every
little volume has a little bit of weight
a very little bit of weight but it adds
up over enormous volumes and even
stranger this stuff exerts negative
pressure it pushes things apart and
makes the universe actually have an
accelerated expansion instead of a
slowing down expansion which is what
you'd expect from ordinary gravity on
very large scales so the challenge is
what is it and we don't know how do you
go about and answering a question like
that or coming to terms with it well one
way is to do experiments and that's very
important but if you have no idea of
what it is and your attempts to do
experiments to find out have been
frustrating you find that you're
measuring zero over and over again you
search for an alternative or if you're a
theorist who doesn't know how to do
experiments also you have to
you have to consider a different
strategy so another strategy is to try
to improve the equations of the part of
physics we know what does that mean to
improve them well it's well before I get
to that we're in a fortunate situation
that way because we think we understand
the behavior of matter in extreme
conditions that's another aspect of
asymptotic freedom things simplify at
very very high energies or it's short
distances so our description which
simplifies in those regimes is perfectly
tailored to the needs of Big Bang
cosmology we're in the early moments of
the universe you had a lot of stuff
which was very hot very energetic and
very stuff together so that's what we
really understand well geology is hard
cosmology is very easy and here's the
proof that's how the simple how simple
the early universe looks here's an
experiment at the so called ric
accelerator where people collide heavy
nuclei together and extreme energies and
for very over very limited volumes for
very limited times produce the sorts of
temperatures and conditions that haven't
been seen in the universe for the last
ten to the ten or eleven seconds years
rather and it looks complicated but if
you follow that strategy I mentioned
afoul of looking for looking at the
flows of energy momentum rather than
trying to resolve every single particle
then you can reconstruct even from such
a complicated topology of events with
thousands of different tracks emerging
that there was in that collision down
there a hot fireball that has the kind
of properties when determined when
described in terms of Prout of quarks
and gluons that we use in our
description of the year
the universe that they're weakly
interacting that they form a kind of
quark gluon plasma so the early universe
is user-friendly to us which means that
if you have some guess for how to
improve the equations that has
cosmological has consequences producing
new kinds of particles we can trace
through the evolution of the universe to
see how those particles would have been
produced during the Big Bang and then we
can go out and look for them we can go
out and look for exotic properties for
instance we could if you have a theory
that predicts a new kind of particle
that interacts very very weakly with
ordinary matter and is produced roughly
enough to make the dark matter well
maybe it is the dark matter so that's
how the aesthetic quest for improving
the equations can tie up with the
physical quest for understanding the
universe now the main strategy that
physicists have employed very
successfully over the course of the 20th
century in trying to improve their
equations is to try to extend the amount
of symmetry that they have special
relativity was an example of this where
you try to make the laws look the same
to observers moving at different speeds
electrodynamics is a more intricate
example where there's something called
gauge invariance which very roughly
speaking is the possibility of adjusting
the zero of the electric potential
independently at different places which
has a profound implementation in quantum
mechanics QCD was an extension of
electrodynamics to have an even more
extensive symmetry and so forth general
relativity was a postulate that even
more extensive motions than uniform
motions at a constant velocity leave the
equations the same
so I'll go through this quickly there
are many exciting and interesting
attempts now or suggestions for how to
improve the equations one is based on
the similarity I mentioned between the
strong interaction and the electro
dynamic interaction where quarks are
similar to electrons and gluons or a
generalization of photons that suggests
since they are described in the same way
that there could be a more profound
theory that had those as sub theories
where they would be manifestations like
different sides of one die different
ways of looking at one richer overlying
reality they could be combined or
unified into an encompassing theory
doing that in detail suggests new kinds
of experiments proton decay because well
I won't go into why and supersymmetry
supersymmetry is another kind of
symmetry which postulates the
possibility of extra dimensions extra
dimensions of a different character than
the ordinary dimensions to space and
time that we deal with in familiar
experience or even in special relativity
these extra dimensions are quantum
dimensions they're very small if you
move into the extra dimensions what
happens is that your spin changes you
change from a spin zero particle into a
spin 1/2 particle for example and if
supersymmetry is an approximate property
of the world that's very exciting
because it means that there have to be
many more particles corresponding to the
particles we know boost it into those
extra dimensions so when they peak out
into the extra dimensions they have to
look different and also implementing
supersymmetry gives you dark a candidate
for what the dark matter is improving
the equations of QCD and improving the
spelling here should be QCD protection
gives you another suggestion for a new
kind of particle which remarkably enough
also is a candidate to form dark matter
beautifying the equations of the
electric and weak interact the
electroweak interactions suggest the
existence of new kinds of particles
called the Higgs particles which are a
big target of future accelerators so
this theme of extending the symmetries
of the equations is a very rich one and
suggests the way to make progress in the
future of physics but physics is
ultimately an empirical science and
these beautification of the equations
wouldn't be fertile if they didn't lead
to definite predictions now each of the
things I mentioned does lead to definite
predictions but it would take me four
Moore's colloquia of this size to
explain them properly I just want to
give you the merest hint of one of the
most compelling ideas and I think one of
the most exciting ones as a way of
climaxing so I mentioned the idea that
the different kinds of interactions look
are described by mathematically similar
theories so we have the electromagnetic
interaction actually this is not quite
that it's the so called hyper charged
interaction but let's just say it's the
electromagnetic interaction for
simplicity the strong interaction which
is mathematically similar and described
just by a different coupling constant
and a different symmetry and the weak
interaction which is also described by
similar mathematics and we would like to
think that there all aspects of one
unified theory but there's a big barrier
to that at first sight if they were
really all aspects of the same thing
they should have a similar strength that
would be part of implementing an
extended symmetry that includes all
these symmetries of the separate
interactions as sub symmetries however
when you study the strength of the
different interactions at accelerators
here you find that they don't have the
same strength
there's a reason that the strong
interaction is called the strong
interaction and the electromagnetic
interaction isn't and the weak
interaction is even called the weak
interaction the reason is that the
strong interaction is stronger so it's
inverse coupling which is pictured here
is smaller than the inverse of the
electromagnetic coupling and so the
unification does this possible
unification of these doesn't seems to be
a non-starter however the great lesson
from asymptotic freedom was that the
power of these interactions changes with
energy or equivalently changes with
distance and we would expect the most
basic interactions to be the ones that
occur at the highest energies or the
shortest distances so what we need to do
to see if this hypothesis of unification
really works whether it can be made to
work is to extend this calculation for
the strong interaction which is
experimentally verified and shows how
the interaction gets weaker at higher
energies or equivalently shorter
distances to extend this to the other
interactions and to extend the whole
calculation to much higher energies and
we can do that with the stroke of a pen
it's the same sort of calculation and
when we do that using the kinds of
dynamical vacuum we know about for sure
the kinds of virtual particles we know
about for sure it almost but not quite
works but if we do it including that
hypothesis of supersymmetry I mentioned
then it seems to work quite accurately
and we get an unexpected bonus that not
only do the different interactions of
element of the standard model of that we
really that we study ordinarily at
accelerators the weak strong and
electromagnetic interactions unify but
if we plot it on this same graph also
gravity which acting as a force between
element
particles is ridiculously small between
compared to the other interactions so it
starts it's inverse coupling would start
out way up here somewhere maybe over
there it also changes with distance in a
way we can calculate and it turns out
that it unifies very nearly with these
other ones too so we're encouraged in
our speculations and beautifying the
equations leads to its needs to not ugly
consequences but still more beautiful
Cossack with the beautiful surprise it
works better than it should have worked
or then we had a right to anticipate but
is it true ultimately experiment is the
arbiter and in this case we'll find out
soon because these ideas of
supersymmetry require that there be a
new world of particles that are not too
heavy and in fact their masters are such
that they should be accessible at the
next great accelerator the Large Hadron
Collider being built again at CERN near
Geneva the US has shirked its
responsibilities in recent years here
but that's due to start operating in
2007 and within a few years after that
we'll see if these beautiful ideas about
improving the equations by improving
their symmetry unifying the different
interactions including the possibility
of extra quantum Dement dimensions and
supersymmetry whether all those would
seem to come together and form a
beautiful package really govern the
world or not it's a very exciting
situation
so I had two great lessons before now
I'm prepared to add one more in
conclusion I stick by this one if we
work to understand we can understand we
learned that even more difficult and in
exceedingly inaccessible problems like
what is the dark matter can start
yielding to theoretical insight by
demanding more beautiful equations we
get candidates we get possibilities for
understanding what the dark matter is
the part of the world we understand is
strange and beautiful that hasn't
changed we're only trying to make it
more beautiful but the third lesson is I
hope you'll agree we still have a lot to
learn thank you
[Applause]
okay so now I'll take questions either
about the top of the subject of this
talk or anything else I may not answer
them but I'll take the questions yeah I
can't see very well so you'll have to we
have a quick okay someone who has a
question just come to the mic and
all right this lady would like to know
[Music]
yeah yep yeah strange things happen in
Stockholm at the time of the Nobel Prize
including some strange events in space
and time I'd like to show you that here
is the banquet hall let me expand this a
bit where the great banquet is held this
is a basically a Town Square covered up
so that you can have town events in the
winter and the Nobel banquet which is a
banquet for 1,400 people including the
Swiss the Swedish royal family down to
third cousins the prize winners and
their guests and a lot of the government
and members of the Royal Academy people
like that it's it's a difficult ticket
to get and but there's a but 1400s means
of very elaborate preparations and
because these are such August people
they don't like to wait around for their
food so they have to be a lot of waiters
prepare to serve everybody
simultaneously the King goes first that
but then everybody else gets the same at
the same time so the logistics are quite
daunting preparations go on for a long
time to record to do justice to this
whole event would take quite a lot of
patience but to aid us what they've done
is make a photo by taking pictures every
15 seconds and then running it as a
movie so here are the preparations and
the occasion of the Nobel banquet
[Music]
that little table is
[Music]
lights going on and off that's
rehearsals of the opera that comes
together with the banquet the whole
banquet is accompanied by scenes from
the Magic Flute this year
and now you'll see the waiting staff
rehearsing
[Music]
if the eye
[Music]
the places are set
[Music]
the waitstaff Rico is a dress rehearsal
[Music]
handles a bit
and now people start arriving
[Music]
people eat very fast
[Music]
magic
student union
[Music]
so I hope you'll agree that
[Applause]
you see the universe really is a very
strange place okay yes okay the question
is the string theory answer some of
these questions I think in its present
form
it doesn't really answer any questions
it poses a lot of questions and gives a
lot of some hints about what the answers
might be but it doesn't really supply
algorithms or definite predictions so
it's a very interesting and promising
thing to work on but at present it's
more questions than answers I was
wondering what is it what does it
actually mean the energy at a particular
point to be oscillating what what is the
what is the energy of a point in space
can you describe that any more than than
that well yeah in principle what you're
supposed to do is surround the point by
a scale well the scale is a little okay
in principle the principle the right way
to do it is you look at look at the
neighborhood of your point see how much
it's curved by throwing gravitons at it
and scattering and see how seeing how
much there it's curved and that gives
you a measurement of the curvature of
space-time which is directly
proportional to the energy momentum
density and then you look at smaller and
smaller volumes and that gives you the
energy momentum density of course you
you don't actually have energy at a
point you have a certain density at a
point that's a highly idealized
description of how operationally you
would do it I'm afraid
in this in this context I think that's
as as deep as I want to go into it we
could discuss it privately there's much
more to say about it
yes for this great lecture and I was
really intrigued by the point you made
that the mass is the frequency
yeah itself and I was wondering could
you comment and how that relates to how
does the internal state of mind and
thoughts relate to the external state
and matter because their internal state
is more of frequencies vibrations and
external yes this suggests I mean this
what I've told you about is hard
scientific facts every you know until
the very end where things good things
were labeled speculative and are
speculative certainly the first part of
the lecture is talking about ordinary
matter these are very hard rigorously
tested battle-worn consequences so I
mean fad scientific facts as you know as
as hard as they get I think so so there
really is that rigorous sense in which
mass is frequency the mass the masses of
particles really do correspond to
frequencies of stable vibrations in the
void and we really are in a sense
children of light that is we made out of
protons and neutrons primarily which
seem we seem to be very heavy and
weighed down we're actually produce out
of very light particles and gluons and
almost massless quarks now then it's up
to you how poetic you find it it does
not in itself I think lead to
metaphysical or theological consequences
what I so when when you when we
discovered that we're children of light
I didn't wouldn't want to put a
theological spin on it but having said
that what does emerge clearly as I said
is that the world is very strange and
very beautiful
and then we should we can admire it and
be happy to live in it
and happy that we can learn about it too
oh yes yeah I can hear you I'll repeat
the question my question is you talked
about gravitons earlier yes what do you
think would be the implications if we
were to actually experimentally detect
gravitons like how much of an impact
would it have on like the questions you
write discuss okay so the question is if
we actually detected gravitons what
would that what implications would that
have for questions that I discussed so
let me put that in a broader context one
of the real one of the exciting
frontiers one of the main frontiers
including here at MIT of experimental
Astrophysical research is the the quest
to detect gravitational waves
now gravitational waves are not
individual gravitons they consist of
many many gravitons acting together in a
sort of bose-einstein condensate if you
like or just two coherent wave and there
are firm theoretical predictions that
gravitational waves really do exist
there are estimates of the strength that
they have they're very weakly
interacting with matter as I sort of
alluded to so they're very difficult to
detect but people are optimistic they've
worked very hard to make very sensitive
detectors are optimistic that they'll
start detecting gravitational waves
before too many more decades are out
and that would be very exciting would
teach you would be like a whole new form
of telescope that's especially attuned
to the most violent events in the
universe because it's only violent
events that produce enough of these very
very weakly interacting waves to be
detectable and furthermore since the
waves are so interesting interacting
they penetrate so you can indirectly see
what's going on deep inside exploding
stars for instance or maybe from the
early universe so that would be very
exciting but that wouldn't be the
detection of single gravitons the
detection of really quantum effects in
gravity so you you have to worry about
small numbers of gravitons would be a
real surprise there because well it
would mean that that gravity is behaving
very differently than conventional
extrapolation of what we know because if
you estimate start estimating based on
what we know the interaction of into
individual gravitons with any detector
that we're likely to have not just for
decades but for many centuries is it's
too feeble to be practical now having
said that there are some heterodox ideas
about gravity that indicate that maybe
very high-energy gravitons interact more
strongly I don't think they're very
likely but just because of that if those
ideas turned out to be true and we found
that accelerators gravitons being
emitted that would indicate that they're
indicate that they that high-energy
gravitons in behave in a way that's very
different from what suggested by the
low-energy forms of gravity we've
observed so far that would that would
really be a dramatic discovery that
would dramatically impact and basically
falsify what I was telling you at the
end but I don't think it's likely
because I think what I told you at the
end is really
compelling excuse me um I'm not a
trained scientist I've never so what I
have my question is probably trivial and
light of what you've been talking about
what I still can't wrap my head around
Planck's constant could you kind of
summarize briefly what that as possible
okay the Planck the Planck's constant
that appeared in my equation the
equation I used relates energy to
frequency so it's the idea that when you
have well in its simplest and original
form that Planck invented it it says
that when you have light that light is
really created is put is composed of
particles so-called photons and that the
energy of each photon is proportional to
the frequency of the light and since
energy and frequency have different
units you need a conversion factor and
Planck's constant is the conversion
factor so it's e equals the energy is
Planck's constant times the frequency
and it's that it's that which enables us
to really make this connection between
frequencies of vibrations and energies
and masses I'm fascinated that you did
the work for which you won the Nobel
Prize during your graduate studies yes
and I'm thinking I'm not going to win
one
I am I'm curious if you knew the
implications of that work at the time
yeah I I had a pretty good idea that
this I didn't I didn't have confidence
that it was correct but I did know that
if it would that is that it was a
correct description of nature but I did
have confidence even at that time that
if it were correct it was very important
and and would would represent well
potentially Nobel Prize material right I
didn't I say something like that yes now
it's much clearer in retrospect what the
significance of our calculations were
and the smooth the nice pictures of jets
that I showed you of course weren't
available then the clues were much much
more indirect and and harder to
interpret any fool could have discovered
the theory if they had those pictures
and so the the experimental evidence I
thought it was much more ambiguous or
difficult not not as compelling it took
several years to really do that also the
ideas we were proposing that the
fundamental ingredients were of the
strong interaction where these particles
you never saw famously
had never seen no one had ever
discovered a quark or a gluon and on the
other hand our theory did not contain
any of the particles you did see didn't
have protons explicitly or neutrons or
anything else was a little
nerve-wracking but what what was a gift
from heaven that made all this possible
and made us made me think right from the
very beginning that this might be the
answer is that the property of
asymptotic freedom that the interaction
should get weaker at short distances and
or at high energies equivalently was
something you really needed to have the
consistency of special relativity and
quantum mechanics work to the bitter end
in quantum field theory and also it was
something that was a strongly hinted at
by the experiments that professors
Freedman Kendall and Taylor later not
won the Nobel Prize for and that
requirement of asymptotic freedom was so
difficult to achieve that there was
basically only one theory that even
remotely looked like it had
simultaneously had that property and
could describe the strong interactions
so it was all or nothing either this was
correct or it was not so that was a good
situation really focused the research
effort and ultimately paid off hi could
you comment on the significance of the
Nobel Prize to you not as a scientist
but as a person maybe some anecdotal
you're the same person but so many
things have changed well I haven't
really absorbed it yet things are still
changing so I haven't reached any kind
of steady state I don't know how it's
gonna play out
I liked the life I had before
I'd like to keep it an ad there's
certainly many opportunities to air the
question is trying to make sure making
sure it doesn't edge out the things I
like before and but having said that I
mean there's no turning back i I was
very unhappy not to have this marvelous
work recognized for so long so there's
no you well be careful what you wish for
but I definitely wished for it and it's
a lot of fun so there are there are huge
pluses and some potential dangers that
I'm gonna have to learn how to cope with
that's a vague answer but I'll have a
much more concrete
answer in a year or so when when I
understand it better have you got a
favorite physics joke what's that
a favorite physics joke well I'll tell
you I'll tell you Albert Einstein's
favorite joke which I like very much
although it's not directly about physics
it is profoundly about physics it
involves a man who's who can't get his
car to start or his car more accurately
he can get his car to start but only
after a lot of effort and this is an old
story so he's he has to crank and sort
of kick the car and push it but he can
get it to the gate to the to the
mechanic and he takes it to various
mechanics and asked them to fix the car
and none of them can fix it he tries one
mechanic after another and each of them
examines the car or tries different
things takes it apart puts it together
but they can't fix the problem then
finally he finds the seventh mechanic
who looks at the car takes out his
wrench tightens a bolt and says now your
car will work and it does work then it
works perfectly so the man is delighted
that his car works drives at home but
then he's very unhappy when a few days
later he gets the bill the bill is a
hundred and fifty dollars he can't
believe it
150 dollars for screwing a simple bolt
he's so outraged that he storms back to
the mechanic and says how dare you
charge me $150 this is when money was
really money so you should mold
Moulton should multiply by 50 probably
how dare you charge me $150 for that
repair it took you of about 30 seconds
to fix that very little labor was
involved all you did was take out your
wrench and tighten a bolt I want an
itemized bill that accounts for that
hundred fifty dollars so the mechanics
takes out his pad and itemizes the bill
parts zero labor 15 cents for turning
screw knowing how to turn screw $149 and
85 cents I'm sorry I blew it knowing
which screw to turn $149 and 85 do you
believe that in the observable future or
ever at all will be able to control
reactions between element like
elementary particles the way we do
chemical reactions get some practical
use of them say like energy sources so
yes so the question is whether we'll get
practical results from understanding
these fundamental interactions better
and well
let me answer that in several ways
because it's a question I'm often asking
is it is a it's a profound question
first of all there are direct
implications for the rest of physics
because as I showed you it opens the
early universe to examination because
things simplify it suggests how to unify
the different interactions and it also
is a great help in interpreting
experiments because most of what happens
at high energy accelerators is the
strong interaction we need to understand
that very very well if we're looking for
the rare events that correspond to
something fundamentally new so those are
interactions those are applications
within physics that are very real and
very actively pursued as to sort of
engineering applications
I think the direct applications are not
yet visible and may never really be
visible but I'm not sure about that I
think as time goes on and as petroleum
dries up as an energy source becomes
very expensive or unavailable altogether
and and also it's pollution starts to
have markedly horrible effects mankind
if it's if it's going to maintain its
current standard of living we'll have to
turn more and more to nuclear energies
and knowing the fundamental theory of
how the nuclei interact may turn out to
be important in understanding that kind
of nuclear chemistry as opposed to
ordinary chemical chemistry certainly
that hasn't happened yet
but as I told you our ability to
calculate these things which relies on
powerful computer technologies has
recently come into fruition we can now
actually calculate the mass of the
proton and other things from first
principles so I don't think it's at all
absurd to think that 10 or 20 years from
now we'll be able to calculate
properties of a
McNew CLE i from first principles and
that will really help but much more
immediate and maybe more important is
the fact that doing fundamental research
like this inspires some of the brightest
people in the world bright young people
to work very hard learn difficult things
work together push the possibilities of
what's possible and push the frontiers
of what's possible and time and again
that kind of focus that kind of effort
has paid off in ways that are unexpected
with vast multiples of the amount of
capital that was invested so for
instance Faraday's investigations into
the force of electromagnetism which were
just pure research and big science at
the time by the way ultimately led to
all the electrical and radio technology
we have today
similarly basic investigations in
quantum mechanics have led to micro
electronics and computers and lasers and
in this even more abstract stuff of
fundamental particle interactions it was
in order to facilitate communications
among large collaborations of
experimentalist at CERN that the world
wide web was developed Tim berners-lee
developed the hypertext protocols and so
and browsers and for that very purpose
so so these investments in pure research
pay off in unexpected ways since we're
running since they're unexpected I can't
tell you exactly what they're going to
be but history indicates I think very
convincingly that putting challenging a
lot of talented talented talented people
to
stretch their imaginations and and work
hard pays off I was wondering about the
t-shirt on that you have on underneath
your suit jacket this t-shirt yeah the
question is alright I think we well I'll
keep answering questions but yeah this
t-shirt comes from a head shop in
Amsterdam I don't know what it means but
if you if you take the appropriate drugs
you maybe will be able to figure it out
[Laughter]
fantastic talk by the way
thank you um I heard some some questions
that maybe the next generation of
particle colliders would create
conditions in which you might create
what I'm create create high enough
energy conditions that for some reason a
tiny black hole might spawn to be
created which could be very dangerous is
this possible at all or is it completely
well there are two there are two
questions there are two questions there
so the first question was or statement
was that you've read that there are
theoretical speculations that at very
high at the next generation of high
energy accelerators one might produce
small black holes and that's true
otherwise respectable physicists have
suggested that kind of thing in an
earlier question I was asked about the
possibility of detecting single
gravitons and I alluded to the fact that
they're a heterodox theories where
high-energy gravitons behave quite
differently than what you would naively
guess by extrapolating what we know
about low-energy gravitons it's in those
kinds of theories that you would
possibly produce black holes because the
high-energy gravitons are interacting
stronger so those go together and I've
told you that I
don't like those theories but some
people do and we don't know but even in
those theories the black holes the
so-called black holes that you would
produce would actually be so small that
they would be highly unstable
they'd evaporate very rapidly by Hawking
radiation so they wouldn't look very
much there they wouldn't look grossly
different from particles they'd just be
heavy particles with that would decay
very fast the details of their behavior
would be different so you could you
could try to convince yourself that they
were well described as rapidly
evaporating black holes but they would
be evaporating very rapidly and would
not create any hazard that's not to say
that nature is so invent not so
inventive and malicious that it's a
logical possibilities a logical
possibility when you do something that's
never been done before
that'll lead to a catastrophe but but
there's no real indication that that
we're close to that famous last words
anyway just to conclude I've never been
so confident though of making a
prediction as when I was called to sit
on a panel about the possibility of an
accelerator turning on and ending the
world predicting that it won't is very
safe because if your prediction is wrong
[Laughter]
okay so I I think with that it's
appropriate to and and I'll answer other
questions in private thank you
you